[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de face aux territoires sur tv5
monde avec nos partenaires vous le savez
ouest france nice matin france antilles
le groupe centre france la montagne et
20 minutes vous retrouverez bien sûr
cette émission sur les sites internet
numérique de nos partenaires voilà
aujourd'hui nous allons consacrer une
émission à ce nouveau gouvernement nous
allons tenter de comprendre quelles sont
ces défis est ce un gouvernement qui ait
fait aussi pour les législatives qui
arrive dans quelques jours avec deux
invités sur ce plateau ce matin deux
éditorialistes deux analystes de la vie
politique soizic mnr bonjour et merci
d'être là sinon il est rédactrice en
chef du service politique de marianne
merci d'être ici ce matin et christophe
barbier bonjour vous êtes majeur de
réaliste politique vous avez vous les
deux d'ailleurs écrit des livres là
c'est la dictature des vertueux soizic
mnr qui est co écrit avec françois aubel
du figaro aux éditeurs aux éditions
buchet chastel
on le voit d'ailleurs vous et puis
christophe barbier vous c'est à la
recherche du héros perdus tout un
programme chez fayard on va en parler
dans cette émission des héros vert du
poil à une émission consacrée donc à ce
nouveau gouvernement
avec vous deux éditorialistes politiques
on va tout de suite partir à rennes
françois xavier le franc le rédacteur en
chef de ouest france à une question à
poser depuis rennes on écoute les
françaises et les français vont
apprendre à connaître leur nouvelle
première ministre elisabeth baume qui
connaissait finalement assez peu parce
que c'est une femme assez assez discrète
on dit d'elle qu'elle est bosseuse
qu'elle est compétente qu'elle est aussi
autoritaire en tout cas elle est
aujourd'hui la chef de la majorité et on
ne peut s'empêcher de penser à la suite
est-ce que elisabeth bornes n'est pas
finalement une des personnalités qui
pourraient demain joué un rôle majeur
dans la course à l'elysée puisque c'est
aussi l'après macron qui s'écrit à
partir d'aujourd'hui soizic mnr bonne
question oui alors on se pose toujours
cette question des quelqu'un arrive à
matignon se dit l'étape suivante c'est
obligatoirement l'elysée je pense que
cette trajectoire est un peu brisé sous
emmanuel macron alors on met de côté
edouard philippe mais regardez par
exemple jean castex personne n'imagine
que jean castex se lance dans la course
à la primaire à jouer même 1,27 même pas
lui-même qu est ce qu il a dit qu il a
quittée sinon il a dit je vais aller
m'occuper de mes volets je vais repeint
de marambat ramallah ce qu'il a confié
en tout cas au parisien donc elisabeth
bornes pour l'instant on voit bien elle
a envie d'être efficace mais elle a
envie de pousser les réformes des
manuels macron n'y a pas une feuille de
papier à cigarette entre l'elysée et
matignon à n'avaient pas de poids
politique avant d'arriver à matignon des
pelles qui a choisi son directeur de
cabinet ce qui est quand même un signal
sous l'oeil ne savait pas été le cas
pour edouard philippe mais le cas pour
jean castex donc son périmètre d'action
politique personnelle est quand même
assez restreint après on va voir
regardez edouard philippe s'est
découvert à matignon mais s'est
découvert dans les six derniers mois à
la faveur d'une pandémie
c'est ce qu'on souhaite pas il avait
deux bornes parce que c'est un
gouvernement christophe barbier pour
gagner des législatives est ce qu'il a
été conçu pour ça c'est un gouvernement
pour ne pas les perdre c'est à dire
c'est un gouvernement qui doit ne rien
faire en tout cas de ne rien faire qui
fâche les français d'ici le 12 et le 19
juin donc on l'a nommé tardivement pour
ça c'est un gouvernement où il manque
des portefeuilles transports logement
ville tourisme donc on a créé une sorte
de gouvernement à trous qui est priée de
travailler dans le silence et de ne pas
se faire remarquer des cils 12 et le 19
juin évidemment ça marche pas parce
qu'il ya tout de suite des polémiques
qui viennent les villes et les tuiles
tombe sur la tête de deux des nôtres
évident comme un avis très très vite
mais ce gouvernement est là pour ne pas
dire la chose qui va fâcher les français
ne pas parler de la réforme qui va
fâcher les français et faire perdre 10
20 30 ou 50 sièges voilà c'est soizic
quemener et christophe barbier
éditorialistes politiques qui sont les
invités de face aux territoires dans un
instant sur ce plateau stéphane bern et
de ouest france
[Musique]
bonjour stéphane bern et vous êtes
rédacteur en chef délégué vous êtes
directeur de la rédaction de paris de
ouest france le premier journal
francophone du monde dans un instant
nous allons qu un interviewer nos
invités avec vous sur ce plateau mais
tout de suite bruno le maire qui était
notre invité le 17 février dernier sur
ce même plateau nous parler de la
stratégie du gouvernement celle de miser
sur la croissance et l'insertion on
écoute bruno le maire
l'austérité et la rigueur ça ne marche
pas ça conduit à plus de dettes plus
difficile plus de chômage et moins de
croissance nous notre stratégie c'est
d'abord la croissance et
l'investissement
les réformes de structure et les
économies là où c'est nécessaire et bien
avant voilà à quoi qu'il en coûte ce
coup l'austérité à la rigueur ça ne ça
ne marche pas est ce que est ce que
c'est toujours d'actualité est ce que
est ce que bruxelles est d'accord avec
ce type de proposition est-ce que ça va
pouvoir tenir dans la durée pour selon
vous
bruxelles et berlin pourrait ne pas être
d'accord très longtemps mais tout de
même depuis la pandémie on voit que les
schémas européen classique ont changé de
nature et qu'il ya une prise de
conscience en europe une croissance à se
stimulent que la stabilité de la monnaie
ce n'est pas tout et que dans un monde
qui est rattrapée maintenant par la
stagflation c'est à dire à la fois une
croissance molle un risque de croissance
molle et une inflation très très forte
il faut d'autres critères économiques
alors si la france engage des réformes
de fond elle pourra se permettre de
continuer à faire tourner le financement
public pour stimuler l'économie mais
l'un ne va pas sans l'autre voilà il
faut montrer qu'on va une voiture je
faut être courageux et montrer que sur
le structurel à long terme on travaille
et dont l'importance est évidemment de
la réforme des retraites a lancé pour
pouvoir sur le conjoncturel continue à
faire le pompier de service donc la
réforme des retraites était essentielle
le s qu'est ce que ça fait partie des
choses qui vont devoir être négociée
d'emblée ça commence quand priorité faut
il faut aller très vite mais on voit
qu'il ya quand même un retard à
l'allumage c'est à dire que l'on n'a pas
deux on n'a pas aujourd'hui de réforme
tout fait on voit bien elle a expliqué
que le 65e 65 ans elisabeth borrel a
expliqué dimanche dernier que c'était
pas un totem on entend parler de 64 on
sait assez floue on voit bien que rien
ne sera dit avant les législatives
sur ces questions là qu'il a fallu un
marqueur un moment dans la campagne
présidentielle
et le problème des marqueurs c'est qu'il
faut ensuite les transformer en réforme
en réforme acceptable par le pays et en
même temps évidemment dans un
environnement donc il faut aussi envoyer
des signaux à l'extérieur donc là c'est
une partie très difficile qui se joue au
début du quinquennat est ce que quelque
part dans la majorité il ya quelqu'un en
embuscade sur cette affaire je pense à
edouard philippe qui avait voulu
rappeler pendant la campagne
présidentielle juste avant crantée cette
affaire en disant non la retraite elle
de se faire comme ça et ce qui est un
problème là dessus ou pas dans la
majorité oui il ya un flou dont la ligne
le président lui même nous a dit 65
avant le premier tour pour plaire à
l'électorat de droite
et puis après on peut discuter pour ne
pas déplaire à l'électorat de gauche
donc il a lui-même installé ce flou il
ya une ligne filippo juppéiste en effet
de la rigueur des comptes publics et
puis il ya une ligne plus plus plus à
gauche qui considèrent qu'il faut mettre
toute une série de critères à plat et
que peut-être la dépendance peut être
financé un peu autrement bon bien
entendu de ce côté là il ya une bataille
de ligne remarquons quand même qu
edouard philippe avec sa volonté de
passer en force sur l'âge pivot juste
avant le confinement il a provoqué une
crise politique le 49-3 une crise
sociale dans la rue tout ça pour aboutir
à quoi à une réforme mort d quand on
parle de remettre les règles les règles
à plat je vais utiliser une expression
qui est à la mode en ce moment est ce
que ça veut pas dire finalement que la
france va essayer de désobéir à l'europe
là les critères ce dessert les critères
de maastricht sont suspendues jusqu'en
2023 on a appris cette semaine donc
désobéir à l'europe on voit bien que
c'est pas ce que veut faire emmanuel
macron mais il a quand même voulu
envoyer un signal quand il sait quand il
s'exprime et quand il s'est exprimé
devant le parlement européen en
expliquant qu'il fallait changer
l'europe mais de l'intérieur c'est
l'éternel débat de l'extérieur de
l'intérieur sur le côté et puis
finalement ça n'avance pas at elle donc
on désobéit parme il faudra changer les
règles au cours du quinquennat oui on
croirait presque entendre la nuque
puisque là aussi il ya tout un débat sur
désobéir à l'europe ou bien changer mais
changer les règles en europe ça ne se
fait pas par la volonté d'un pays qui
voudraient imposer le plan b est une
mythologie ça se fait par un tour
d'europe où vous essayez de convaincre
tout le monde que ce la bonne direction
et celle là c'est ce que macron a réussi
sur les travailleurs détachés à minima
dans son premier quinquennat et puis
surtout à la fin avec les allemands sur
l'emprunt européen on a réussi à faire
emprunter au niveau européen pour
financer un plan de relance ça c'est une
révolution donc pourquoi ne pas penser
d'autres révolutions dans fonctionnement
de l'ordre une question sur bruno le
maire comment est-ce que vous jauger son
positionnement au sein du gouvernement
alors c'est peut-être un détail pour
vous mais il a été le premier à annoncer
dans l'ordre protocolaire c'est
important donc il a un grand ministère
mais c'est pas forcément celui qu'ils
attendaient ce que toute la partie de
transition écologique les chapes oui
mais il a la souveraineté industrielle
s'est à nouveau monde souveraineté on
l'a en alimentaire chez ces industriels
et les numériques il ya la volonté de le
remettre au coeur d'un ministère
régalien puisque la souveraineté série
gagne en nous cette place de numéro de
cirque il est ministre d'état même si on
appelle plus l'a16 savez ça me rappelle
quand eux quand ils dit cresson avait
été nommé premier ministre il y avait
pierre bérégovoy qui était à bercy et
qui rêvait d'être à matignon il n'avait
pas été donc on lui avait donné un super
bercy on l'avait même appelé à ce moment
là pierre 1er de bercy par le jeu de
mots et pierre 1er de serbie eh ben pour
moi bruno le maire il est dans cette
position là et jean launay ont réussi la
quadrature du cercle avec le meti voilà
mythique est un ministère gigantesques
ils se sont même reconstruit sur cette
conception absolument il ya un autre
aspect des choses qui est intéressant
c'est que en fait il a avec lui
gabriel attal ministre délégué chargé
des comptes publics gabriella talent
c'est un ministre qui a été
hyper performant en terme en tant que
porte parole du gouvernement ces
dernières années est ce que ça c'est une
c'est ainsi c'est une équipe une équipe
de rêve qui peut marcher alors on sait
qu'il ya des liens entre les cabinets il
fonctionne très bien de façon très
fluide ça c'est très important dans un
organigramme gouvernementale toi merci
on dit surtout à bercy on à gabriel
at-elle qui effectivement est la
personnalité qui a explosé pendant le
premier quinquennat qui sait parler aux
français c'est important un doux qui
s'il saura dire ce qui se passe skins
inquiétudes évidemment sur les comptes
publics c'est à dire vous parliez tout à
l'heure d'austérité à quelle sauce vont
être mangés on entend beaucoup que en
tout cas c'est ce que c'est ce que
disent ce qu'ils discutaient avec
emmanuel macron que finalement la loi
qui va nous est présenté sur le pouvoir
d'achat sera la dernière loi généreuse
du quinquennat donc ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'on va arriver dans un dans
un quinquennat va falloir faire très
attention aux comptes publics donc ça va
être vraiment
c'est le pivot enfin la discussion le
pivot bercy la discussion entre les deux
hommes est la représentation médiatique
des choses doit être à l'unisson dont
quatre qui travaillent vraiment ensemble
mais effectivement ça rajoute du poids
politique à bercy en sachant que le
maire ça a été dit il est numéro 2 c'est
le grand vainqueur du remaniement je
pense
qu'elles sont pas bien là dessus sur le
duo ça a fonctionné entre les deux on
envoie une photo derrière vous il danse
elle fuit les aux gens que gabriella
talent c'est macron c'est un bébé macron
aussi donc il ya aussi cette
surveillance de l'elysée sur sur bercy
après la pandémie bruno le maire m'avait
dit que à travers l'épreuve de la
pandémie mais aussi celle des ligier les
jaunes il s'était rendu compte qu'en
france il ya que deux administrations
qui tenait vraiment la route l'armée et
les finances à bercy on va il est la
tête d'une des deux alors vint écoutez
maintenant regardez plutôt un des
collaborateurs de ouest france qui est
dessinateur qui s'appelle chaunu c'est
traditionnel dans cette émission qui a
une question à poser sous forme de
dessin en fait les problèmes commencent
déjà
bonjour emmanuel macron à ramener dans
ses filets à gauche l'historien pap
ndiaye et à droite le président du
groupe lr à l'assemblée nationale damien
abad mais de gros nuages noirs
s'amoncellent au dessus du gouvernement
et elisabeth bornes ne connaîtra pas
d'état de grâce d'un côté on accuse le
nouveau ministre de l'éducation
nationale d'être le promoteur et aise au
clis il a déclaré qu'il existe dans la
police nationale racisme systémique de
l'autre on accuse le ministre des
solidarités et du handicap damien abad
de viol alors que la justice a classé
sans suite les plaintes alors la
question que je pose n'assistons nous
pas à une américanisation de la vie
politique française et est-ce une bonne
chose des freins de ferme est question
corollaire la alors l'américanisation de
la vie politique française moi je crois
pas que c'est une bonne chose mais
heureux et physiquement on voit qu'il ya
un certain nombre de problèmes qui ce
qui s'accumulent juste moi j'ai une
question sur le fait que la première
mesure le premier projet de loi qui sera
discutée en fait qui est en cours
d'élaboration se portera sur le pouvoir
d'achat est ce que dans les problèmes
qui s'accumulent s on a ri parce qu'on
va réussir à un moment à sortir de la
dichotomie ou de l'opposition entre fins
de mois et fin du monde
christophe barbier la fin de mois
l'emportent sur la fin du monde
franchement oui oui depuis la pandémie à
la guerre en russie certes les problèmes
d'urgence sont devenus tellement grave
le hic son lumières durant le prix
alimentaires sol ils sont liés bien
entendu la clé du blé si on regarde la
galaxie on ne veut pas que l'opinion
explose comme un volcan et que ça se
termine dans la rue faut d'abord
répondre aux besoins d'urgence besoin
d'urgence et faire le plein de la
voiture quand on doit faire 20 km pour
travailler tous les jours et nourrir et
se nourrir voilà et donc c'est d'abord à
cela qu'il faut répondre d'où cette loi
pouvoir d'achat ça n'empêche pas de
penser le long terme et de se dire bas
pour ne plus être dépendants du gaz
russe on va construire du nucléaire bah
tiens ça tombe bien ça nous permettra
aussi moins polluer on peut articuler
les deux mais si la réponse d'urgence
n'est pas à donner vite et si elle n'est
pas satisfaisante à l'automne tout va se
bloquer vous aurez la france dans la rue
le gouvernement il pourra plus rien
faire ni du conjoncturel ni lui
structurelles donc le pompier d'abord
l'architecte ensuite ben c'est vrai que
sur la question du long terme c'est
d'autant plus important pour emmanuel
macron que c'est son dernier quinquennat
donc la question aujourd'hui c'est
quelle place va-t-il laisser dans
l'histoire et en direction des jeunes
générations évidemment il a besoin de
répondre à la crise climatique
il est très attendu là dessus et donc il
va falloir trouver des réponses très
vite donc on voit bien il a mis un
tandem a mis le nom d'alain amis
espagnols une hache et chargé justement
de ces questions là non pas pour valeur
elles sont pas connus pour être
spécialement écolo mais revanche pour
l'efficacité pour délivrer selon un
terme qu'on offrait souvent mag redis
c'est à dire donner des résultats très
vite donc effectivement pouvoir d'achat
et ensuite il va falloir montrer qu'on
est par exemple dans les territoires les
gros rouleurs puisque ça va être un des
des premières cibles du gouvernement
comme on aide les gros rouleurs à
comment à se déplacer tout en ayant un
allant vers une transition vers
l'écologique et donc vers la voiture
électrique qui disait le choix d'un
tandem donc deux personnes qui sont
parties qui ont connu pour être très
efficace mais peu connu du grand public
est ce qu'il n'ya pas aussi derrière
tout ça la volonté pour emmanuel macron
de continuer à incarner seule cette
thématique de la transition écologique
de make our planet gratteux guen cap à
un calcul aussi par rapport à sa sainte
de qom c'est lui devant les français
c'est lui devant l'histoire donc on
connaît on connaît on connaît la
propension des manuels macron a amené
justement ce face à face donc il ya le
face à face avec les français qu'on a vu
lors du grand débat etc et là il ya le
face à face avec l'histoire sur cette
question là mais effectivement tout ça
alors il n'ya pas l'administration il
n'y a pas d' administration à l'elysée
donc en termes d'efficacité ce sera du
côté du gouvernement mais en revanche
évidemment il va piloter cette façon
très serrée et ces deux personnalités
ont été choisies parce qu'elles
s'entendent très bien avec elisabeth
bande mais c'est aussi des personnalités
qui sont repérés depuis lé quinquennat
précédent par l'elysée à tel point
d'ailleurs qu emmanuel macron a demandé
à l'espagne et une hache et de ne pas
être candidate aux législatives parce
qu'elle était dans une circonscription
difficile qu'ils pensaient qu'elle
risquait de ne pas être élu et donc vous
savez quand on n'est pas élu on doit
quitter le gouvernement le 19 juin ça
montre aussi les limites du et en même
temps c'est à dire autant il a pu faire
des prises de guerre à gauche et à
droite autant sur les écolos bas
personne n'est venu yannick jadot aurait
très bien pu dire voilà la transition
écologique vais la faire j'ai des
différends avec emmanuel macron mais je
vais faire des choses non il a préféré
rester dans l'opposition il ya un
problème sur les personnalités non
connus de ce gouvernement il y en a trop
rien en ont une patronne il ya beaucoup
de personnalités reconduites donc le
grand changement nouveau peuple nouveau
président nouvelles méthodes il aurait
pu incarner plus fortement alors on
verra après les législatives
il y aura un autre train de nominations
mais là sur les les postes les
principaux du pays ce sont les anciens
qui commande ce sont pas les nouveaux
ses fonctions législatives puisqu'on en
parle vous avez vous créé des surprises
est ce qu'il peut se passer des choses
c'était jean luc mélenchon premier
ministre son nom jean luc mélenchon
prémunissent j'y crois pas parce que
l'arithmétique du scrutin et beaucoup
trop violent dans des législatives il va
y avoir une grosse abstention 53 % la
dernière fois ça peut monter encore donc
il faut être dans les deux premiers pour
être qualifié les triangulaires y en
aura pas eu une seule la dernière fois
donc si au deuxième tour vous avez macro
contre mélenchon dans des
circonscriptions l'électorat de droite
et d'extrême droite éliminés il fera
barrage il fera barrage au candidat
mélenchon donc il y aura un premier tour
peut être triomphale pour la nuque et un
deuxième tour beaucoup difficile devant
faciliter finalement la majorité la
pastille bleue l'idée de la majorité de
se retrouver après ça fera quand même
une opposition extrêmement compliqué à
l'assemblée parce que vous aurez
beaucoup d'élus de gauche et notamment
de gauche radicale mélenchonistes sans
doute beaucoup plus d'élus d'extrême
droite qu'il n'y en a jusqu'à maintenant
et donc il y aura une taille autour du
groupe majoritaire les débats vont être
très très très virulent groupe
majoritaire qui va vite se diviser en
écurie présidentielle
merci beaucoup ses fans vernay a très
vite jeudi prochain tout de suite denis
carot le directeur des rédactions du
groupe nice matin sur ce plateau dans un
bonjour denis carot vous êtes directeur
des rédactions du groupe nice matin
olivier dussopt pts le nouveau ministre
du travail de l'emploi et de l'insertion
était notre invité le 20 janvier dernier
ici même sur ce plateau il affirmait que
le pic inflationniste en france allait
s'estomper au milieu de l'année 2022 on
écoute ce pic inflationniste a selon
christine lagarde vos questions à
s'estomper au milieu de l'année 2022
pour revenir dans des taux d'inflation
beaucoup plus normaux est beaucoup plus
classique
alors on peut pas dire qu'olivier du
surf dans cette déclaration et été
particulièrement visionnaire le rôle
précise ses propos ont été tenus un mois
avant le début de l'offensive russe en
ukraine l'inflation c'est la difficulté
majeure et le pouvoir d'achat c'est le
principal sujet du gouvernement quelles
réponses concrètes doit-il à porter
surtout comment peut-il montrer que
c'est sa priorité
je pense qu'il faut aller très vite et
d'ailleurs les premiers signaux qui ont
été envoyées cette semaine sont assez
étonnant c'est à dire que on apprend que
la loi ne sera pas présenté alors pour
des raisons techniques parce que d'être
présenté en commission des finances en
même temps que cet homme est un problème
non notamment dans la perspective dans
la perspective de législatives voilà
parce qu'à une très grosse attente
effectivement il suffit de regarder les
journaux télévisés tous les jours c'est
le sujet qui revient le prix des fruits
et légumes le panier de la ménagère
comment boucler la fin de mois les
français qui utilisent de plus en plus
de crédit à la consommation le lit est
moins d'argent sur le livret a donc tous
les signaux sont là pour montrer que les
français sont très inquiets donc
effectivement il faut des réponses sur
ces questions là donc on est en suspens
là il ya eu à un moment le gouvernement
avait hésité d'ailleurs à convoquer
l'assemblée nationale bien avant pour
dire il faut aller très vite sur ce avec
cette majorité actuelle il a fait avec
la configuration actuelle de l'assemblée
il faut aller très vite moins ils ont
décidé de ne pas le faire donc là
effectivement s'est remis à après des
législatives avec un gros point
d'interrogation donc il va y avoir une
présentation n'appelle sans parti c'est
du conseil des ministres donc on va
avoir les grandes orientations m'ont les
a déjà chaque alimentation là l'inde la
ré indexation des pensions de retraite
sur l'inflation etc mais je pense qu'il
faut encore autre chose c'est-à-dire
qu'on a besoin de mesures beaucoup plus
ciblées beaucoup mieux ciblés pour qu'on
soit pas dans un arrosage comme on a pu
l'être avec un ouvrage un saupoudrage ou
alors comme on a pu l'être en baissant
par exemple de 18 centimes le litre le
litre à la pompe en sachant que tout le
monde en a bénéficié
alors qu'il fallait et que cette mesure
qui s'arrête et va sûrement du coup
devoir être prolongée va exactement avec
denis carot christophe barbier et près
de 68% des français mécontents de ce
gouvernement quand même un très mauvais
démarrage c'est un très mauvais
démarrage il est normal qu'ils aient pas
d'état de grâce un président réélu que
dis-je réélu reconduit après une
campagne un peu frustrante ça ne pouvait
pas donner un élan d'enthousiasmé dans
ce pays mais à ce point là y'a pas
d'effets bornes malgré le fait que c'est
une femme qu'elle a des qualités 90 les
français n'ont pas été enthousiasmés
portée est absolument aucun effet du
remaniement et puis le président de la
république à force de vouloir gagner du
temps sur les campagnes électorales bah
il crée des trous d'air aussi dans ceux
dans ce démarrage donc ce qui va
vraiment lancer leur la relation entre
cet exécutif et l'opinion ça sera les
premières décisions ça sera le pouvoir
d'achat la solidité or on voit bien
évidemment que tout le saupoudrage
toutes les mesures conjoncturelles
d'urgence a suffit pas donc le vrai
débat c'est celui qui a lancé bruno le
maire en disant aux patrons augmenter
les salaires allez-y augmenter les
salaires mais là il faudra du temps pour
qu'il y ait du répondant c'est là que le
gouvernement joue beaucoup l'écart entre
ces le ce timing un peu curieux qui a
consisté à apprendre beaucoup de temps
avant de désigner
elisabeth bornes et le gouvernement
cette composition du gouvernement où
effectivement la moitié étaient déjà
présentes est-ce que emmanuel macron ne
s'est pas planté
en fait il s'est planté facialement
c'est-à-dire grappelli à l'instant les
français ne sont pas heureux de ce
gouvernement et comprennent pas quelle
est la nouveauté ou l nouveau président
il fait pas rêver mais après c'est un
c'est un gouvernement de peur sans
gouvernement qu'ils étaient construits à
l'envers c'est à dire on fait venir
c'est on voit bien que c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué pour les raisons de la
sphère abad mais on fait venir le
président du plr ont fait venir un
historien à l'éducation nationale
monsieur pape ndiaye en disant on en
voit un signe aux aux profs aux
syndicats de profs à la gauche est ce
qu'ils ont moins voté pour la nuque donc
on voit la difficulté c'est de réussir à
voir une majorité large mais surtout une
majorité on en parlait tout à l'heure
une majorité sans edouard philippe parce
que si c'est edouard philippe si c'est
le groupe même s'ils sont que 30 qui
permet d'obtenir la majorité ça veut
dire qu emmanuel macron sera finalement
dépendons et notamment pour la question
de la réforme des retraites d'edouard
philippe donc il a créé les conditions
d'une sécurité sur les législatives et
cette sécurité sur les législatifs et
qu'on n'a pas de flamboyance politique
on s'attendait à mieux c'est vrai la
part d' emmanuel macron de vichy prend
son risque là c'est plutôt de la
sécurité lors il ya un double risque
pour le législatif à la fois le scrutin
et les résultats du scrutin lui même et
puis la composition de la majorité sur
un président qui ne peut pas se
représenter c'est un président qui perd
très vite toute autorité françois
mitterrand 88 réélection triomphale et
derrière le ps refuse de canards boiteux
américain ray très vite très vite et à
l'époque ça donne le congrès de rennes
et l'explosion complète de la gauche y
mitterrand contrôle plus rien il va
arriver cela à emmanuel macron parce
qu'il ne veut pas se représenter
peut-être même que même si les jeunes
christophe barbier mais le plus jeune
président de la vème république tous
saluent les chapelles ont fait réagir à
un jour y reviendra m'a bien sûr ses
propres amis vont lui dire écoute
président formidable bravo occupes toi
de poutine et de la sauver la planète
laisse-nous gérer le pays parce que la
prochaine fois c'est nous qui allons
devoir éviter les extrêmes c'est pas toi
et il y aura cette compétition alors
évidemment on voit edouard philippe
lamonde pour ceux pointés comme comme
dauphin il y en aura très vite d'autres
quand même parce que les autres écuries
ont pas vouloir lui eut laissé le champ
libre dans las et soizic quéméner
rédactrice en chef au service politique
de marianne et christophe barbier
éditorialistes politiques qui sont nos
invités ce matin notre partenaire du
groupe centre france la montagne
aujourd'hui christophe darne de l'éveil
de la haute loire il en est le rédacteur
en chef à une question à nous poser
depuis le puy en velay on écoute
christophe barbier bonjour les candidats
aux prochaines élections législatives
sont 20% moins nombreux qu'en 2017 dans
le même temps plusieurs ministres
sortants ont annoncé leur volonté de
quitter la vie politique comme jean
baptiste djebbari ou adrien taquet
d'autres personnalités ont décliné un
poste au sein du nouveau gouvernement
alors selon vous est ce que la politique
souffre aujourd'hui d'un manque
d'attractivité et pourquoi
c'est tellement violent de s'engager en
politique vous devez faire la
transparence sur tout ce que vous
possédez la moindre mobile est le
moindre véhicule mon appart y compris
votre vie sexuelle votre vie sexuelle la
transparence parfaite dire aussi qu'ils
sont vos amis parce que les conflits
d'intérêts ça peut ça peut jouer est ce
que votre beau frère votre cousin votre
enfant votre grand-père à des postes non
et c'est quand même terrible ce qu'on
demande alors au nom de la probité
publique un boxer c'est légitime mais
pour maintenant s'engager en politique
soit il faut avoir 70 ans avoir fait sa
carrière et se dire tiens ça va me faire
un bâton de maréchal soit il faut
vraiment avoir la vocation chevillée au
corps et puis dans le phénomène que nous
traversons actuellement il ya aussi bine
l'épuisement des familles politiques
classiques ps et l air qui font qu'il ya
toute une toute une série de deux
motivations idéologiques qui ont disparu
notons qu'il ya moins aussi de candidats
aux législatives
parce que la gauche se rassemble et donc
il ya moins de dispersion et puis la
majorité s'étaient largy aussi elle
digère beaucoup de l'ancien socialiste
ou d'anciens élèves et donc là aussi ça
ça à éponger les candidats mais on a
quand même six mille deux cents et
quelques des candidats pour 500 places 1
517 places ça variait de quoi faire
alors il ya des signes inquiétants à la
participation aux élections en baisse il
ya de moins en moins de militants on le
voit là il ya de moins en moins de
candidats ce que c'est pas tout
simplement que notre système
démocratique est malade soizic est
mineure ça c'est sûr que c'est
l'événement police et le point politique
de ce quinquennat c'est à dire la
participation en baisse à chaque
élection intermédiaire avant par rapport
à ce qui s'était passé auparavant alors
là on part quand même de très bas c'est
à dire que pour les législatives de 2010
est au premier tour on était à 52 4 %
d'abstention je crois si ma mémoire est
bonne en tout cas plus de 57 % seront
tour ce qui était hallucinant quand vous
regardez par exemple la circonscription
de jean luc mélenchon au premier tour en
2010 être 8400 voix pour jean luc
mélenchon alors évidemment il a été élu
ensuite second tour la question de la
légitimité ne se pose pas mais en
revanche c'est vrai que ça montre une
désaffection et ça peut produire
d'ailleurs des mouvements très fort
c'est dire que vous avez un dissident
qui est très bien implanté c'est ça des
places 200 voix et 200 voix ça change
beaucoup dans une élection avec un si
petit si petit nombre d'électeurs alors
effectivement il ya ceux il ya toujours
cette cette sensation d'inachevé c'est à
dire qu emmanuel macron devait moraliser
la vie politique ce qu'il a essayé de
faire avec les lois du début du
quinquennat mais aussi réconcilier les
français avec leurs dirigeants il l'a
dit à plusieurs reprises n'a pas réussi
à le faire alors il ya plusieurs jeunes
ministres prometteur qui ont décidé de
quitter la vie politique qu'est ce que
ça dit christophe barbier basse a dit
qu'une carrière maintenant c'est pas
forcément 50 ans à s'accrocher au
moindre mandat et ses jeunes talents ils
peuvent avoir commencé en politique
parce qu'ils ont milité étudiants et
puis l aventure macron puis aller dans
le privé maintenant aller dans des ong
et revenir dans cinq ans dans dix ans
dans 15 ans dans 20 ans et je pense que
c'est encore une fois à l'america est
méritée on rentre dans l'élite rations
et on en sort on peut aller avec privé
on peut revenir exactement avec cette
différence que en amérique quand on est
battu dans des élections importantes
normalement après on s'arrête en france
quand on est battu on n'est pas mort ça
va permettre aussi de faire tourner et
d'appeler plus de gens aux
responsabilités et notamment plus de
femmes la parité n'est pas atteinte dans
les candidatures aux législatives
certains partis font même de très
mauvais scores dans l'investiture et
donc ça il faut vraiment le corriger
peut-être que faire circuler les élites
c'est bon pour la parité un grand
professionnel puisque vous me
fournissent et une transition formidable
on va parler dans un stand elisabeth
bordent les femmes en politique merci
denis carot vous êtes le directeur de la
rédaction du groupe nice matin dans un
instant armelle le goff qui dirige la
rédaction de 20 minutes et sur ce
plateau
[Musique]
bonjour armelle le goff bonjour et saufs
barbier viens de parler des femmes en
politique elisabeth bornes la première
ministre était notre invité il ya
quelques semaines le 10 février dernier
notamment sur ce plateau elle disait son
optimisme vis-à-vis du problème que
ressentent le plus les français l'emploi
des jeunes on l'écoutait à moi je suis
très optimiste sur les possibilités pour
les jeunes en général pour les jeunes
cadres en particulier de trouver un
emploi et donc qu'ils sont aussi dans
une bonne situation pour négocier leurs
salaires
alors justement est-ce que le défi du
prochain quinquennat ce ne serait pas
les salaires et l'attractivité des
emplois puisque on voit que dans
certains secteurs on peine à recruter il
faut payer mieux faut payer mieux parce
qu'il ya une pénurie de main-d'oeuvre
cccc mécanique et c'est urgent ça
n'empêche pas à côté de regarder de
manière un peu sourcilleuse ceux qui
jouent du système pour peut-être ne pas
reprendre un emploi alors qu'ils
pourraient le faire on peut serrer la
vis comme ça a été fait sur l'assurance
chômage mais il faut d'abord augmenter
les salaires tout travail mérite salaire
en fonction de la pénibilité de de la
nécessité et il faut vraiment rendre
cela attractif par ailleurs il faut
réfléchir aussi à une nouvelle politique
d'immigration
on gère très mal et l'immigration dans
le pays ça crée des tas de problèmes il
ya sans doute une partie de
l'immigration qui n'est pas bien gérée à
l'arrivée mais aussi parfois une
immigration qu'on devrait susciter parce
que c'est bon pour notre économie et ce
sera bon pour les pays d'émigration
parce qu'ils récupéreront après des gens
qui auront été formés on aurait dû créer
un recréer un ministère de l'immigration
pour réfléchir justement une immigration
dédiées à certains secteurs d'emploi je
pense que cette au ministère de
l'économie de regarder avec les secteurs
comment avoir une politique bien gérée
scène et 'gagnant-gagnant' de
l'immigration saisonnière ou provisoire
avec des étudiants qui viennent quelques
années se former et qui après retour
dans leur pays faire profiter de leur
expérience avec armelle le goff un
casting gouvernemental le ministre vert
même en bonne place oui exactement et
autres grands causses du quinquennat un
voulu et revendiquée par emmanuel macron
l'égalité femmes hommes est ce qu'il est
mal embarqué sur cette question avec son
casting gouvernemental
quand il que alors au début non c'est à
dire vous avez une femme première mini
c'est la deuxième fois que ça arrive
sous la république vous avez deux femmes
connaissent manière une hache et amélie
de montchalin qui sont chargés m'en a
parlé tout à l'heure de la transition
écologique vous avez peur aussi aux
outre-mer voilà et vous avez une femme
aussi qui est porte parole donc ça veut
dire que toutes les semaines la pas et
dans les médias la parole venu du
conseil des ministres viendra d'une
femme olivia grégoire tout ça a été
installée et patatras arrive la sphère
damien abad avec toujours ces questions
sur qui savait quoi quel moment et ça on
voit bien d'ailleurs dans le dans
l'énervement de la réponse d'elisabeth
bornes qui est une réponse est très
nette serait direct 1 dès dimanche matin
là les censeurs de même ne savait pas
alors c'est toujours difficile de c'est
toujours difficile de répondre à ce
genre de question en revanche ce qu'on
sait de ce que dit médiapart c'est que
matignon a été appelé mais ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que entre entre appeler
quelqu'un à matignon et que
l'information arrive et soit signalée
comme intéressante importante et on lui
remet russe qu'elle remonte au premier
ministre on n'a pas de remaniement avec
un premier ministre qui vient de
s'installer donc là il ya quand même un
gros point d'interrogation
après on peut dire que le système
d'alarmé ne fonctionne pas après on peut
aussi dire que l'association qui a fait
remonter le signalement qui se présente
comme un observatoire mais c'est une
association qui a été créée par des
militantes de la cause féministe dont
alice coffin qu'on connaît bien et donc
est ce que est ce que cet observatoire
été repérés c'est à dire que j'imagine
que cet observatoire si la peine dans un
ministère dans un mot tout le monde va
répondre tout de suite au téléphone mais
il a été créé en fait visiblement en
tout cas ils envoient des mails et dans
leur boîte mail que personne ne consulte
un puisque oui mais c'est alors après il
faudrait une enquête de police que je
que je n'ai pas fait pour savoir qui a
reçu le mail qui a ouvert le mail mais
il ne veut on peut entendre qui aidé
énormément de mails qu'ils soient reçus
après on peut aussi se poser la question
il y avait des alertes qui venait de
chez l air il ya des ministres et l'air
que non pas être ta les alertes ou des
boules puantes
bas il ya les deux toujours les deux et
c'est la figure du traître damien abad
il était président du groupe plr à
l'assemblée et il va au gouvernement
donc s'est il amusé il expliqué au début
de la semaine qui va mettre du temps à
se décider qui se décidera le vendredi à
la pensée que c'est le jour de la
constitution du gouvernement donc
évidemment s'est suicidé inimitiés ça
ramène des villes aussi à la surface
qu'ils sont barbier il a même pas besoin
d'être critiqué par son camp damien abad
il est déjà dans les problèmes au lieu
sur blessure il est déjà dans les
problèmes après on voit bien que la
règle ancienne un ministre démissionne
quand il est mis en examen elle est plus
valable il ya des ministres mis en
examen qui reste comme eric dupond
moretti il y a des ministres à qui on
n'avait rien à reprocher de judiciaires
qui ont craqué françois de rugy donc
c'est un comportement personnel est ce
que je suis en capacité d'exercer ma
fonction et puis c'est surtout une
question de résistance politique est-ce
qu'on me défendrai ce que je peux
organiser ma défense politique et là on
voit bien que damien abad et de ce côté
là et est remonté il suit se défend ni
les tresses elle lui adresse le goff et
ce qu'il peut y avoir un bras de fer sur
le sujet entre la première ministre qui
semblait quand même très contrariée par
cette histoire ce week-end et le
président de la république qui lui
visiblement considère qu'à partir du
moment où il n'y a pas de faits
judiciaires il n'y a pas de raison de
verser la somme du président qui
l'emportent pour l'instant mais comme
l'a dit elisabeth board s'il ya des
éléments nouveaux des faits nouveaux on
regardera plus près jusqu'à c'est une
question de caractère est ce qu'elle est
capable de résister à emmanuel macron la
première ministre swazi et madère alors
j'ai aucune aucune question sur sa
capacité nerveuse
faut lutter à brax près après la
question c'est la différenciation
politique vis-à-vis des manuels macro
mais je pense que c'est même pas le
sujet c'est dire que jean castex c'était
quelqu'un qui avait du caractère qui
savait se défendre et qui en même temps
était totalement alignée avec l'elysée
je pense que c'est exactement ce qui va
se passer avec elisabeth board skin
amoindri pas ses qualités mais qui
juste la réalité d'une situation
politique cyril boutique et le directeur
éditorial de france antilles à une
question à nous poser depuis fort de
france à propos on en parlait il ya un
instant de cette nouvelle ministre des
outre mer il ya elle brune piv et on
écoute depuis fort-de-france
bonjour la nouvelle ministre des autres
maires il ya un gros hiver a déclaré
dans nos colonnes qu'elle avait les
capacités pour renouer les fils du
dialogue avec les ultramarins selon vous
quelle est sa marge de manoeuvre pour y
parvenir
allez on commence par vous soit zik ça
c'est une très très bonne question en
tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que le
rapport entre emmanuel macron et
l'outre-mer est aujourd'hui rapport
électorale en tout cas catastrophique
quand on regarde or les gens lui voulant
soins qui est arrivé voilà en fait qui
marine le pen et marine le pen vous avez
alors il ya un contexte particulier on
sait celui de la vaccination des
soignants n'empêche c'est une
catastrophe pour emmanuel macron c'est à
dire que au début du quinquennat
précédent il volait au secours des
antilles après les événements
climatiques
il a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup misé sur
sa relation avec l'outre-mer et là on
voit bien qu'il ya quelque chose de
brisé donc effectivement le travail
d'abord ça va être de raccommoder et
c'est un énorme travail yaël brawn pires
est la bonne personne à ce poste elle
était quand même président de la
commission des lois à l'assemblée
nationale elle se fait remarquer sur les
questions de fin de vie oui et puis
beaucoup de caractère parce que
plusieurs fois on évolue la compagne de
les sessions son poste et je pense
qu'elle a deux qualités pour rabibocher
emmanuel macron avec cette france de
l'outre-mer d'abord
il faut une avocate pour pour emmanuel
macron elle à cette formation là et puis
il faut un peu de psychologie faut un
peu de doigté on ne commande pas avec
des tableaux de chiffres et puis des
relations technocratique et là je pense
qu'elle a une capacité d'écouté
d'empathie qui pourra être précieuse
rappelez-vous comme ça avait été utile
pour l'époque jacques chirac d'avoir
françois baroin communiste de
l'outre-mer qui avait développé aussi
cette capacité d'empathie c'est d'abord
être à l'écouté comprendre les blessures
profondes qui sont celles de l'autre
mère notamment sur la la vaccination où
il ya un malentendu terrible une
dernière question qu'elle incarne
suffisamment par exemple ne pas avoir
gardé quelqu'un comme marlène schiappa
puisque ce n'est pas une erreur une
personnalité qui va vraiment au front au
charbon qui soutient le président sa
politique à tout crin en tout cas il
faudra des femmes de caractère comme
marlène schiappa dans cette nouvelle
équipe les caractères pur furent gier
olivier grégoire par exemple la porte
parole ne s'en laissera pas compter ni à
l'assemblée ni dans les ministères et je
pense qu'on pourra voir surgir des
figures vraiment politique dans la
partie féminine de la distribution
gouvernementale merci armelle le goff
vous êtes directrice de rédaction de
20minutes partenaires de cette émission
nous allons maintenant écouter sébastien
lecornu le nouveau ministre de désarmer
aragon l'appel aux yeux c'est même pas
la défense nationale c'est les armes et
l'appellation et on a gardé cette
appellation l'aller je crois en temps de
guerre on appelle le miz désarmé mais il
se désarmer c'est ça et encore la
novation c'est parce que le chef
elle de la défense il est à l'elysée que
là on fait la tendance voilà en tout cas
une autre invitée en tant que ministre
des outre mer donc le 21 janvier dernier
et ils nous donnaient et nous disait sa
définition du bon portefeuille
ministériel on écoute
aux mystères idéal c'est mieux ça dans
lequel vous êtes utile avec une mission
vont peut être ministre de quelque chose
de prestigieux cia rien à y faire quand
on a 35 ans est un mouroir
alors quand on a 35 ans pour vous
sourisseau 10 km à l'expression et cet
exercice est toujours intéressant de
réécouter les ministres après ça me sert
très prestigieux il il va avoir comme
comme principal travail de garder les
budgets lui ces discussions permanentes
avec avec gabriel et à la tall matin
midi et soir puisque c'est ça c'est la
grande réussite de ce quinquennat en
tout cas du point de vue des armées
c'est d'avoir réussi à ré enclenché un
mouvement aurait investi dans l'armée
alors pas pour des bonnes raisons et
l'a5 vu le contexte international met
donc il faut qu'il arrive à défendre sa
daube lui va être plutôt dans la défense
de ce qui a été fait après c'est
clairement l'une des récompenses pour
services rendus en idée devenue
instable mais indispensable est devenu
l'un des maillons centraux du dispositif
politique d' emmanuel macron notamment
dans les relations avec les élus en
puisqu'il est il est toujours président
du conseil départemental de l'eure alors
politiquement on le classe ou alors
évidemment macro nice mais il était
proche de bruno le maire d'ailleurs dans
la géographie territorialement mais en
même temps il est proche des dauphines
oui oui ça va être une passerelle aussi
sur cette droite delà de la macro nine
pour faire en sorte que ça se passe bien
et que ça ne tournent pas vite à la
cohabitation et puis que la compétition
2027 ne viennent pas trop parasites et
cela dans sa proximité avec le chef de
l'état sur les sujets militaires il va
devoir assurer la mutation l'armée
française depuis qu elle est
professionnelle elle ce concerne elle se
concentraient surtout sur la projection
de forces en afghanistan au liban au
mali etc on voit qu'avec le problème en
russe on revient à l'idée qu'il faut
aussi une armée plus continentale plus
classique ça va être un enjeu budgétaire
mais aussi un enjeu intellectuelle alors
on va coûter maintenant olivier dussopt
optique était également notre invité
c'est le nouveau ministre du travail de
l'emploi et de l'insertion quand il
était sur ce plateau en début d'année à
l'époque ministre des comptes publics
il nous disait ceci écoutons le je crois
que ce qui resserre les liens entre les
élus et gouvernement sont les paroles
tenues
voilà ce sont les paroles tenues alors
les paroles tenues c'est quoi un mode de
gouvernement swazi que la femme devrait
l'être en tout cas oui alors la
difficulté c'est qu'elle part alors on
voit bien emmanuel macron a toujours dit
j'ai fait des promesses en français en
2010 est justement les français n'aiment
plus leur politique parce qu'ils
tiennent pas leurs promesses donc je
vais tenir mes promesses la difficulté
des manuels macro on sait que c'est son
quinquennat a été frappé par les crises
qu'il avait suscité type gillet il ou
pas en tout cas su anticiper type il est
jaune j'ai aussi des crises dont on
disait qu'il pouvait juste subir c'est à
dire la pandémie et la guerre en ukraine
malien donc là emmanuel ma coiffe est
quand même assez peu de promesses
pendant cette campagne donc toute la
question c'est qu'est ce quelle vision
quels espoirs donnés aux français qu'on
n'a pas donné de promesses pendant la
campagne présidentielle et se retrouve
dans une situation un peu d'eux est au
milieu d'un désert aride emmanuel macron
de quoi faire nourrir ça
intellectuellement pour projeter
justement les français vers 2027 vers
2030 2050 là quelques engagements forts
quand même dans ce désert et quelques
oasis il ya la transition écologique
énergétique mon club le casting est là
maintenant faut le faire il ya là
changement des institutions avec une
sorte de commission transpartisane et
puis il nous a promis une nouvelle
méthode avec nouvelle forme de dialogue
dialogue avec les élus locaux quelle
carences dans son premier quinquennat
donc une nouvelle décentralisation comme
on dit les corps intermédiaires dont les
partenaires sociaux donc ça elisabeth
borne peut le faire les partenaires
sociaux mais avec les élus locaux qui va
le faire qui va engager cette nouvelle
décentralisation française qui va faire
à la fois la nouvelle efficacité de
l'état et la nouvelle liberté des
territoires merci christophe barbier
éditorialiste politique et soizic
quemener me jaillir des ministres les
années ça va arriver en chef du service
politique de marianne avoir été nouveau
invité ce matin à jeudi prochain
jean-pierre raffarin sera notre invité
[Musique]